look it's right there it's right there
i've never seen a red dragonfly like
that
it's so pretty good morning guys
i just parked to the huntington library
or at the huntington library that's
proper grammar i'm about to meet up with
jess and we have
a cute little one-on-one girl date at
the huntington library today so
i'm really looking forward to it and i
thought i would bring you guys
because i haven't brought you guys to
spend the day with me in quite some time
so i missed you guys have you been i've
been great
getting my stuff ready i have the
sunscreen hand sanitizer
my invisalign tray thingy because
i know you guys can tell i'm talking
with a lisp jess is waiting for me right
now
at the entrance i brought a blanket and
my hair
and my mask obviously because that's
important and we're just gonna have a
cute little
little girl date i'm so excited
[Music]
what's up guys today our backyard
is getting a make over and it's so
exciting just because
since we moved in we've only had a dirt
patch
in our backyard and going out there has
always been like going into the desert
because it's just like loose dirt dry
a couple weeds there but nothing alive
and it just feels really dead out there
and like the colors just all like beige
everything's beige even our houses beige
so we decided through hard skating and
some landscaping we're gonna
transform it into somewhat of a
continuation of what we got going on
inside the house you know some colors
there
we got fake plants but we're thinking
about doing real plants outside
obviously
and like you know tiff really did a
great job with adding some just colors
everywhere
colors colors everywhere colors colors
over there
colors over here gray and i'm really
really surprised
at how fast these guys are working in
the morning they started loosening up
the dirt jackhammering everything
breaking up the concrete that was here
before they're gonna do
their own concrete pour so i wasn't
monitoring it at
all and didn't really record a whole lot
it just peeked out the windows
oh that's happening i recorded that but
i wanted to go out there and like
and record some but then they were like
hitting stuff there was a lot of debris
and rocks flying everywhere and i'm like
maybe i should stay inside our backyard
is pretty small so i'll stay inside and
watch from afar
five hours later i'm like holy crap
they've got like a whole lot of
foundation work done
i think they're doing electrical right
now too it's pretty crazy what i thought
would be a
like a one month project like a three
week project they're telling me that
they're going to be done in a week and a
half
so pretty fast guys all right
i'm with my date hi look oh my god
oh we're being so bad no bad girls look
you can see my mouth
i know it's so hard to breathe and it's
so
hot outside it's really hot today that's
why i decided to wear something like
light
and airy i really feel like i'm like
running out of breath because of the
it does yeah it's like slowly
suffocating you
i feel kind of funny too with like the
hat the glasses the mask is like you
can't
see my face at all full sun protection
too which is pretty cool
the last time we came to the huntington
library was when we all
like all the jkds we came together so
you could take photos sorry i can't
breathe
i literally can't really do that there's
no one around we can take a break for
like a second
and breathe okay yeah because i'm like
trying to talk
oh it's really hot last time we came we
came to take photos
and that was like over a year ago
because you guys know how often like
casey isaac and i we would come here
because we have a membership and then
the last year
that we had a membership i was telling
casey i'm like man we haven't been
coming for a long time like should we
even renew it okay he's like yeah we
knew it
like for sure we're gonna be coming all
the time like definitely 100
we didn't come once and the whole year
we renewed the membership because
by now it has already expired we
actually came using jess's membership
yeah
there's no renewal going on here i think
once you've been like five
times and like you don't have the desire
and then you guys moved a bit away
yeah we moved further away because you
guys knew that we lived
somewhere near near here but then now
that we live so far away we're like well
i even bother
but i was telling them how excited i was
for our little girl's date
because i'm like justin i don't really i
mean we do but not really really spend
like one-on-one time together
this is nice yeah it's a nice place to
be too very calm
yeah true whoa
i don't know if you guys can make them
out but right over there there's like
these red dragonflies i have never
i think they're dragonflies i've never
seen red dragonflies like that before
and even though the water looks
disgusting oh
oh dang it it stopped it was so close
you don't want to get in this water
that's what i was about to say like even
though the water
looks disgusting it's so hot i want to
get in
oh where's our turtle oh yeah in the
middle look
it's right there it's right there i've
never seen a red dragonfly like that
it's so pretty i think i got it sorta
oh yeah that's pretty i wish i got him
from the side
yeah it looks really good oh that looks
so refreshing
being in the shade is like 10 degrees
cooler
still so good
look at how pretty you know i've been to
the huntington library a million times
and i have never seen this how'd you
miss this one i don't know because we
always come through the other side on
that end
yeah we go through that the lattice area
yeah
exactly so i had never noticed this and
then the very first thing that we walked
through which i didn't really capture
for you guys but
we walked through this area that had a
lot of statues and i was like what the
heck i've never seen this either
so you could come to the huntington
library a million times and miss a lot
of things that's how dense this place is
there's a lot of things to admire this
is so pretty
i can't breathe girl i can't smell
anything oh yeah i've seen this
i've gone through here before they film
a lot of a lot of
shows and movies here i never noticed
this area
or this area it's really pretty
you know they filmed a west world here
yeah down there with the bridge with the
the japanese like like heavily arched
bridge it was the japan scene oh my god
i'm so glad i wore makeup today
it would have been melted off i don't
know oh that's so pretty i love it here
yeah it's so big this is crazy to me
yeah it's huge here so much
land here like in the middle of la
that's just like
taken care of and nice and it's not
residential or industrial it's just
gardens
it's all nature i know this is truly an
amazing place
something to appreciate yeah whenever
there's no one around it's like okay
breathing break if it was like a lot
more windier here it'd be
a lot more tolerable i think with this
heat
but the fact that it's just like really
really hot
no wind very still it gets to you a
little bit but
this is pleasant man i'm so sick and
tired of being stuck at home
all day every day and if it's not at
home then we're filming jk news
which that office has zero windows
so no sunlight no like no ounce of
nature
so it's just really nice to get out and
actually enjoy nature
and like with someone that i don't see
every single day yeah it's really
pleasant
you get to see someone you don't see
every single day
i love you casey and isaac
[Music]
feed the fish
[Music]
yes yes the most beautiful conceited
flower
because i was pointing the camera to
myself all right let's check out
what they've been working on today
[Applause]
bam oh is everyone gone
oh everyone's gone i'd wanted to come
out here and have a conversation be like
hey what's up guys how's it all going
and i think they're all
they've all uh left for the day and uh
i guess i will get updates from them
tomorrow
so just to catch you guys up on what
they did today and i totally missed
on filming it so this is all the
concrete here
that was there so there was a big
thing in concrete here they tore it off
you see where they like just broke it
off from the building
and from what i saw from today is that
they've all placed it inside the ground
here
as part of the foundation put some here
now and this is all part of like the
elevation
so what we're going to have eventually
is have this is going to be like our
deck there's going to be a counter that
comes out from this wall
this way stops and here is a step
so this is going to be elevated here and
then you go you step
down that way and then all that's gonna
be like a lower tier and that's what we
got going on
pretty exciting stuff so yeah so tip
today is uh hanging out with jess
at uh the huntington library i can't
wait for her to come home and check this
out because this is a
really this is already a huge change
from what it used to be already we could
finally breathe
we sat down being responsible distanced
from people um we also got some
housewives
some
[Music]
so this is going to be extremely
refreshing it is
so freaking hot today we get to just
relax
and enjoy the view it's so pretty here
all right so we finished
lunch and we're walking by and then jess
is like oh let me take some photos
of you know you know
just being dressed that's why i love
working i had to get a close-up shot of
[Music]
that all right
we're leaving huntington now that was
quite fun thanks for being my date yes
thanks for coming
i had a great time it's also really nice
to just
get out of the house breathe in some
fresh air when we're allowed to
and just enjoy the nature it was really
nice i i enjoyed it a lot
thanks for inviting me yes it was very
relaxing this is her idea
all credits suggest all right i'm home
now
um i arrived with a pounding headache
because i realized i haven't actually
eaten any food
yet because i i just ate the the ice
cream thing and then the
fruit that you guys saw me eat i will
make you food right now i'll heat it up
but
no it's okay oh but yeah like now that
i'm home he's really excited to show me
the progress on the backyard because
today is the first day that they started
our backyard it's a very very exciting
thing but forgive me for not being super
excited because my
head is like right now so sorry
whoa i'm gonna need to wear this okay
say goodbye to these sandals for the
meantime
oh my god wait can we talk about the
fact that they're curled
oh yeah so these nike sandals
are the same size as these adidas uh
sandals
but look at the size difference now oh
my goodness
that's hilarious and it's because of the
sun right
yeah so like these became my outdoor
sandals and these became the new indoor
sandals
and since they're like in the sun like
the rubber or plastic of this this is
both rubber and plastic i don't know
what the material is but
it just started curling up and like
shrinking in the sun so now
crazy and it feels weird to wear them
and it's really funny because
these have been next to those and look
at them they're perfectly fine
they've been in the sun as well but i
don't know why i use the color because
you know how like black
attracts the heat or whatever maybe it
got hotter probably
it feels like i'm doing this though when
i'm wearing them it's like i'm doing
this
yeah like you're wearing clogs yeah it's
like i'm rocky yeah
okay let's go check out the backyard
whoa
oh that's weird
it's so different look we don't have a
step anymore so it's like
it's a big step wow so they watered all
this stuff right before they left
to create like a compact foundation
they're like really tight
yeah and then i'm assuming that what
we're standing on right now is going to
be at this elevation
so this is so much more oh look they
even added the
they ran the electricity for the grill
and they were working on all this
wow and we have a plug
here that's amazing oh my gosh how
exciting
the door what hey that looks good yeah
they did a clean job
they did a lot today i know i was just
like it's just the first day i don't
need to vlog
much and i like i'll go to editing and
then i turn around and like look out the
window
see what they're doing and then like
it's totally transformed get the camera
oh my gosh yeah but then i don't think
it was very safe because half the day
they were just
breaking the cement yeah
earlier today they had like a like a
ditch here that they dug
they did the piping for like the dragon
oh the drain
this is so cool i know it looks so weird
just to see it
a little bit more leveled because it's
always been like a very like
deep v but now it's not that bad and
then here it's weird seeing it like
leveled fully leveled it's a different
like texture now too
i mean that is not the final one i know
our backyard is finally coming along
i can't wait till it's done done though
and then we're chilling in our l couch
here
yeah and then we just get to like have a
view
yep this is pillows and couch
yep right around here we have to shop
for that stuff too
so we're gonna see what can fix
and i also have to buy the stencil
because you know like for the ground the
stenciling that we said that i'm going
to be doing
on that side over there they want me to
bring in the stencil already so then
they can measure out
exactly how to score the cement so it
could be like a good size
i haven't ordered it yet but we gotta do
that we're taller now look look at how
much more the sea of the
house is that's true we're taller right
now as you see
it's like yeah as tall as the the fence
mm-hmm we're gonna be like uh what's
that one show it's finally oh yeah
home improvement no improvement yeah
because like this is going to be college
though like right
yeah probably so that by the time it's
done
i think my eyelid will be like right at
the end oh dang
i wish they would have been able to lift
the fence higher though yeah
they came and told me about the fence
and they're saying
oh um they're not gonna put concrete up
against this thing
they don't want to mess with it because
they're saying like it's just so flimsy
yeah it's the worst defense ever you
don't want to mess with this fence at
all
cool we don't have a driveway right now
look at all this all this material
there's like a movie set
you're such a boy yeah
[Music]
you